[Music]
one of the most important aspects of
meaningful conversation is listening if
you're asking important questions and
not listening you're not having a
conversation at all you are giving a
soliloquy so one of the easiest ways
that we can practice active listening
and avoid a conversation dead end is to
make sure that we are turning the
conversation more than we're taking it
so I'll give you a quick example so my
sister just comes back from Thailand and
she says I had an amazing trip we went
to the north and the beaches in the
south so here's what a take would sound
like it's like oh I went to Thailand
last year we went to the beaches - so
you see what you just did is you just
directly that thing right into a dead
end and now it's gonna stop so what a
turn looks like is you get to say oh wow
I went to the beaches as well what was
your favorite part
and so that simple turn shows them two
things that you heard what they said and
that you care enough to ask a follow-up
question and I promise you that the best
conversationalist always turn the
conversation more than they take it
because oftentimes what happens is that
it's not our first question that is
going to get the answer or the depth
that we desire so if we commit to
turning the conversation back three and
four times we're gonna peel off those
layers and get more depth out of our
conversations so always remember turn
the conversation more than you take it
and you're going to avoid those
conversation dead ends when we move past
asking better questions we move into the
metamorphic two-step and this is all
about presence and presence is so
important in conversation you've all
said this before she has such presence
he has such presence presence is that
embodied existence in the moment it's
when you're only responding and reacting
to what's happening right now there's no
story from the past there's no fear of
the future and it's a magical thing when
we can create that in conversation and
one of the easiest ways to do that is
something called the metamorphic 2 step
and the metamorphic 2 step is actually a
hypnosis technique that will help you to
identify how you want to feel in social
situations so I learned this from my
friend Andrew who's a hypnotherapist
here in New York City he works with a
lot of the fortune 500 brands quickest
growing startups and basically what he
talks about with some of these leaders
is helps them to identify where they
have anxiety in their leadership roles
and helps them to overcome that really
achieve peak performance and so when I
first met him I said
okay so how would you use hypnosis to
alleviate something like social anxiety
and so what he would tell me is he'd say
okay so what I want you to do is think
about a social situation where you might
have some anxiety and I'd say okay I'm
going into a big tech conference with a
bunch of really influential people and I
might be nervous and he'd say articulate
the undesired state of being what is
that and so I'd say you know I'm worried
that I won't have anything to say I'm
worried that they won't think that I'm
high up enough to actually care about
what I'm gonna say I'm not gonna add
value and he'd said great just by
actually articulating the undesired
State you are naming it and you're
taming it you're gonna be more aware
when those undesired states manifest and
that's the first step and so he said
step two is that you have to articulate
the desired state of being and our
brains are really good at telling us
what is going to go wrong in social
situations because it wants to keep us
safe
it wants people to like us and this
traces all the way back to caveman days
when we were much more tribal and if we
were ostracized by the group we were
gonna get kicked out of the group and
then it was a literal death sentence and
so our brain is still responding with
that type of intensity to social
Australasian and so articulate the
desired state of being so I want you to
tell yourself three ways that you would
like to feel in this social situation so
for me coming into that that conference
I'd say you know what I want to be
authentic curious and present and so now
I've given myself three desired states
of being and I can even take the first
letter of each of those desired states
of being authenticity curiosity presence
acp so anytime any of those fears or
anxieties actually pop up I can just
revert right back to ACP and those are
intrinsic motivators ways that I want to
feel and I could say if I wanted to be
authentic if I wanted to be curious or
present what would I do right now and
now I'm grounded in the present moment
in those desired ways of being I'm in
the present moment I'm back towards
accomplishing and creating presence and
conversation one of the most common
symptoms of starting out or being early
in our career is shyness is just these
feelings of being intimidated feeling
unworthy and we never talk about shyness
because there's a taboo when we feel
shame about it well guess what the
american sociological review
just put out a study a couple years ago
and they found out that 60% of all
people identify struggling with shyness
or social anxiety 60% so if you've
struggled with that kind of intimidation
you've had that self-critical internal
dialogue you are in the majority and so
you need to be easy on yourself and say
that those feelings are natural and
they're ubiquitous everyone has those
and so when we have those feelings we
should notice that most times when we
have that kind of intimidation factor we
feel unworthy we're comparing ourselves
to others we're looking at other people
and saying oh wow there's so much
smarter than I am
oh wow I'm never going to be that good
and so comparison is the thief of joy if
we're constantly comparing ourselves
with other people we're not going to be
able to enjoy the process and it's going
to be very hard to maintain the effort
and energy that it takes to be really
good at something so what's more
important
what's more effective to focus our
energy on is what we want to be really
good at and comparing ourselves with who
we were yesterday if all we do is focus
our attention on being better than we
were the day before we can live that
process for the rest of our life because
again knowing who you are what you care
about and what you want to be is
something that you'll keep defining for
the rest of your life but if you keep
committing yourself to actually
progressing to getting better and if you
can look at yourself a couple of years
ago a week ago a couple of days ago and
say hey I'm smarter I'm better I'm
learning there's gonna be fulfillment in
that
[Music]
you